[Music]
revers LS Dr Freud have given you up for
L Yi is my personal assistant really
well if a patient is calm Yi always
stretches out at my feet but if a
patient is agitated Yi stands at my side
what should I make it is running away at
the sight of me ah well he's also a
fanatic about
punctuality well you have wonderful home
my daughter Anna tried the best to
replicate our home in Vienna forgive me
but why are we you come here to see me
if you disagree so passionately with My
Views to make you realize that you're
wrong well that God you've insisted all
your lives that the very concept of God
is ludicrous yes why someone of your
Supreme intellect could certainly
abandon truth and then Embrace a
ludicrous dream an Insidious lie well I
wholeheartedly disagree well of course
you disagree you have to disagree
otherwise the entire structure of your
childish Faith would collapse into a
rubble
why does religion make room for science
but science refuses to make room for
religion oh please you're breaking my
heart cuz they hide behind their
ignorance you hide behind your ignorance
I think that you're afraid to feel
emotions at all is that your final
diagnosis fascinating I don't know you
don't know well finally finally finally
we're making
[Applause]
progress rely to yourself thinking that
you can control death the way you
control your world and your daughter
Anna is dedicated to the science is she
seeing someone she has no time for
relationships I'm worried about my
father he has no one there must be
someone me that's my girl truth is
you're terrified we're all terrified see
you bury your doubts you bury your
members of the war but at the core of
your being we're all cowards before
death
[Music]